[Music]
6 24 on your Finally Friday you know
last week we introduced you to the
winner of this year's Mojave Max
emergence contest well yesterday was
field trip day for Eden and his fifth
grade class from Rundle Elementary
big fancy bus pulled up and for some
their first time ever visiting the
Springs Preserve
after a group picture onto a classroom
where Springs Preserve zoologist Katrina
Smith and Alex gave the real Mojave Max
some flower petals to munch while they
explained to Mr Monk's class that those
bumps on his back include a transmitter
so they can keep track of him as he
wanders around the 15-acre habitat
congratulations after Javier Rivera
Rojas from County Commissioner tick
segurlum's office presented contest
winner Eden winter certificate it was
Pizza Time teacher Anthony monk says
learning about desert tortoises may have
changed some of the students I think
they're just like super into like
reptilian life now I think I've strayed
most of like the cat and dog lovers into
like snakes and tortoises so I think
they're really enjoying it
all right well both Mr Monk and the
winning student and were given laptop
computers from the folks who put the
contest and our dozen or so annual
visits together a shout out also to get
Outdoors Nevada the Clark County desert
conservation program and the Springs
Preserve John Heather